would you would you um would you try to
get a little
would you try to get back on a roster or
do like the big three thing at all or um
[Music]
uh i don't know i i never gonna say no i
love basketball bro like i just like
playing basketball so i wouldn't rule
the the big three out big three is
always i love watching the big three i
just like playing basketball i like to
see iso joe out there you know what i'm
saying
it's like bro we gonna play anyway yeah
yeah i try and explain to people all the
time they're like man do i wish you just
it's not like you stopped playing yeah
it's like bro i don't not love
basketball i still play like the owners
of that ball club and the gm is going a
different direction that has nothing to
do with iman like you not finna like bro
if y'all want to come to the gym that i
be at like you got to know somebody
right
but it's like dog we be in the gym like
we getting it in right it's just
whether or not
the opportunity is there because i'm
like though
though it's like i'm working my ass off
they can't just be like oh yeah you
might come in it got to make sense like
they got young guys they drafted they
got right right right they got the g
league they got g guys that are already
there that are 22 years old and healthy
right now and under their wing right
it's like me it's hit or miss bro it
honestly is if you you bring it in well
i'm a 10-year veteran right i'm 30 years
old i don't come with well you're not
that old i'm 31. i'm i'm just saying
what i'm saying is if you got a 22 year
old
and you wasn't finna give me the ball 20
times of play anyway i mean 20 times a
game anyway why wouldn't you pay the 22
year old